this is alvin pushing the limits though
literally nobody calls me that
her name is claire king but she's also a
queen oh wow
way to turn it around
today we're talking about the 11 piece
set this is a combo of pots and pans
whether you're a new cook
you're just moving you're in college you
want to just redo everything
this is going to be an all-in-one set
that helps make your tasty dreams come
true as a tasty producer i have to
juggle so many things whether it's
making the food look good making the
video look good and having reliable
cookware is very important to me because
i cannot afford to waste any time like
cleaning too much or having things fail
especially when the shot really matters
so having all this stuff and knowing
it's going to work 100 of the time just
makes my job so much easier and it's
actually the same exact cookware that we
use on tasty videos people ask us all
the time in the comments like where can
it's like no this is it like this is the
cookware that we use go to walmart right
next door driver walmart
in our 11-piece cookware set we have our
nine and a half inch frying pan perfect
for like eggs omelettes i've made a
lasagna in here before we have our two
and a half quart saucepan a one and a
half quart saucepan and a six quart
dutch oven i think this is kind of a
one-pot wonder and you love this one
right this is your favorite pan
the 11-inch griddle when i look at this
i just see a bunch of possibilities
actually thinking of doing a crepe cake
but with a square so that when you stack
it up it becomes a cube
let's go make a crepe cube
and a four quart jumbo cooker i like
this because i can braise a lot in here
so if i'm making like a ragu or
something i can braise the meat on a
really high heat add some liquid
cook it off for a little bit so it gets
like really pully and tender i'm such a
brazer
she's a brazer y'all i'm a brazer
whether you're giving this as a gift or
getting it for yourself
this is an amazing cookware set full of
everything that you're going to need
whether you're just starting out or
you're a seasoned pro
the 11-piece set you can get in store
online at walmart and yeah we hope you
enjoy it as much as we do
[Music]
[Music]
you